[Music]
foreign
an old Japanese tale goes once
challenged a monk to explain the concept
of heaven and hell but the monk replied
with scorn you're nothing but aloud I
can't waste my time with the likes of
you he's very honor attacked the samurai
flew into a rage and pulling his sword
from his cupboard yelled I could kill
you for your impertinence that the monk
calmly replied is Hell started that
saying the truth and what the master
pointed out about the fury the 30
minutes grip the samurai calmed down
seized his sword and bowed thanking the
monk for the inside and that said the
Monk Is Heaven I first read the story in
the Great Book emotional intelligence by
the great Daniel Goldman it was given to
me by a friend some years ago who while
giving it to me also told me something I
could immediately resonate with Adrian I
really believe that the most important
thing We crave for is inner peace we
want the end of struggle inside of
ourselves to find happiness and
contentment we want the cessation of our
inner struggles in this pursuit of a
cessation of our inner struggles as my
friend very creatively put it our path
is full of obstacles every day we
attempt to somehow enjoy the benefits of
a balanced life and every day we
miserably fail to do so we find
ourselves struggling to cope with
opinions of others we become judgmental
we get into arguments and our life feels
like a pendulum constantly oscillating
between anger and despair there is
probably only one way to overcome these
obstacles and eventually help this
pendulum come down understanding our
emotions
[Music]
[Laughter]
imagine a scenario where you were
hitting the nose hard enough to make
your eyes water the moment this incident
occurs some intense physiological
reactions will take place inside your
body your skin will grow hot your mouth
will go a bit dry and your pulse will
become elevated you will also be
overwhelmed with a strong desire to hit
back the person that initiated the heat
eventually you will find that you've
overcome this sudden influx of physical
and mental stimuli what you've just
experienced the basic emotion of anger
has passed now why does a physical
impact lead to so many physiological and
mental changes in yourself most
neuroscientists and physiologists agree
that basic emotional responses like
anger exist as a result of evolution
it's what we commonly refer to as the
fight-or-flight response and it is
usually triggered after we experience a
threat an attack or a harmful event when
such an event occurs the brain processes
the signal from one of its most
primitive Parts which is called brain
stem this system regulates basic life
functions such as breathing the
metabolism of the body's other organs as
well as controlling stereotyped
reactions and movements unfortunately
this primitive brain cannot be said to
think or learn rather it is a set of
pre-programmed Regulators that can help
the body run and react in order to
ensure its survival after that the
signal moves to the limbic system the
place where emotions are produced before
it eventually reaches the neocortex
where rational logical thinking takes
place the neocortex evolved millions of
years later on top of the emotional
areas of the brain the fact that the
thinking brain Grew From the emotional
one reveals much about the relationship
between thought and feeling there was an
emotional brain long before there was a
rational one and this is what makes
humans act with emotion first
most psychologists agree that a basic
emotion like anger exists as an
evolutionary trigger we humans and most
of other animals appear to be equipped
with a set of predictable responses to
situations we call this the basic
emotions which are anger fear surprise
disgust joy and sadness as those were
described in the 1970s by Anthropologist
Paul Ekman while trying to explain the
reasoning behind emotions most of us
will agree that they occur naturally due
to a response to a situation this
response might be either automatic due
to evolutionary reasons or a result of
our own evaluation and judgment the
moment an event occurs in other words
when we experience disgust it could be
the result of a judgment about how we
feel when we see vomit or because our
body undergoes physiological changes
like quizziness and increased skin
temperature at the site of vomit over
time research has also separated other
emotions that most in the scientific
Community believe are only experienced
by humans and some other primates these
are called higher or moral emotions and
are based on self-awareness
self-consciousness and ability to
empathize with others in this category
belong emotions like Pride guilt
embarrassment jealousy and shame the
main distinction between basic and moral
emotions is that they tend to emerge
after self-reflection and the supportive
theory that emotions are results of
judgments rather than simply involuntary
reactions to a stimulus bottom line
higher emotions have started to make
their appearance at a later stage of our
Evolution as humans whether discussing
the origin or nature of basic or higher
emotions one question Still Remains why
do we experience them in the first place
in motions are signals that usually
Fleet after we become aware of them the
best way to describe the function of an
emotion would be as a mechanism that
aims to get our attention and demand the
response but why do we experience the
physiological and mental reactions to
these mechanisms for instance why do we
experience Anger from a smack on the
nose or shame from stealing here the
debate ends and scientific consensus
emerges from an evolutionary standpoint
emotions are the Agents of change and
reaction disgust is a quick nasty
response that we experience when we
encounter something that might make us
sick anger quickly transitions us from a
Placid state to one where we're ready to
fight fear prompts us to flee from
dangerous situations sadness can
generate the resolve needed to change
the direction of one's life emotions can
also motivate us to continue what we're
doing the experience of joy is in a
pleasurable one and we are motivated to
carry out the behavior that led to the
emotion moreover emotions serve as the
glue that helps keep together social
bonds our ability to understand emotions
just by interpreting the other person's
facial expressions signifies the fact
that emotions are also used as social
signals this allows us to interact with
others while understanding their needs
and intentions which is the Bedrock of
society emotions and Society are
strongly attached to each other
especially higher emotions offsprings
are raised in families and that's where
the first idea of attachment and social
bonding is created this attachment is
what prompts us to seek out the company
of others and if we don't do so it leads
to loneliness which further only leads
to the emotion of sadness another
example is the feeling of shame we
experience when stealing higher
self-conscious emotions like shame
prevent us from repeating behavior that
is harmful to others what we are not
sure of is whether Society emerged as a
result of our ability to experience
emotions based on our interactions with
others or the other way around as a
person grows older emotions develop from
knee-jerk physiological reactions to
predictable conditioned responses in
this sense the emotions of the
individual are hijacked by the
expectations of the society the
individual lives in making that person
more suited to live in that Society
conclusion with regards to emotions and
the role they serve we should have in
mind three things number one emotions
are motivators in order to keep doing
what we're doing number two emotions are
reactions towards a threat thus acting
as mechanisms ensuring our survival and
number three emotions higher emotions
mainly are shaped by Society in order to
help the individual living harmony with
others
hi guys this video is sponsored by
brilliant as you know I really do
sponsored videos but brilliant is such
an interesting platform and I couldn't
refuse when they approached me I have
tried many methods of learning over the
years but I'm almost certain that the
best way to learn anything is by doing
it yourself especially by learning
interactively Interactive Learning helps
you learn way more effectively than just
watching lecture videos Brilliance
platform is designed around this idea
take for instance this incredible course
on astrophysics in this course you can
learn intuitively Concepts like matter
radiation exoplanets black holes and
dark matter the structure is great and
you can progress from one topic to the
next gradually and seamlessly I got
hooked and I was playing around with the
course for hours I'm sure that brilliant
is ideal for students who want to deeply
understand the STEM related topics but
it is also perfect for every curious
human who wants to delve into
interesting Concepts like astrophysics
Quantum objects logic and physics of the
everyday to try everything brilliant has
to offer free for a full 30 days visit
brilliant.org slash metamorphosis 77 the
first 200 of you will get 20 of
Brilliance annual premium subscription
enjoy again thanks for watching see you
soon